The solutions for this equation are x equals 3 plus or minus root 7 all divide
by 2. Fantastic work if you found these solutions. I know they were tough. You
might have tried factoring here, but it turns out that we can't. For factoring,
we would have had to find factors of positive 2 that summed to negative 6. But
we know the only factor pairs are positive 2 and positive 1, and negative 2 and
negative 1. Now that are those pairs summed to negative 6, so we can't use
factoring. We also can't use the root method here. We don't have a perfect
square on one side of the equation. Completing the square would also not work,
since our a value is positive 2. You would want the a value to be positive 1
and the b value to be even in order to complete the square. So, using this
quadratic formula, we have a equal to 2, b equal to negative 6, and c equal to
positive 1. We plug the values of a, b, and c into their positions to get this
expression. The root of 36 minus 8 is the root of 28, and we know we can
simplify this root into 2 root 7. Next, we factor a 2 from the numerator,
leaving us with this expression. We cancel the common factor of 2, that appears
in the numerator and in the denominator, which leaves us with our most
simplified form, our answers. We factor a 2 from these two terms to get this
expression. Then, we cancel the common factor of 2 and then the numerator and
the denominator to get our final answers.